I was standing on the banks of the
Catatumbo River in Venezuela when the
group of teenagers turned to me and said
everything's gonna be fine we'll bring
the guns that was when I got worried
where the Catatumbo River flows into
Lake Maracaibo there is something in the
air
it's what the naturalist Alexander von
Humboldt described as electrical
explosions that are like a
phosphorescent gleam
it's what a meteorologist might call a
MCs or meso scale convective system
locals call it the ray Lampe gödel
Catatumbo but you and I would probably
just call it an ever lasting lightning
storm not only does this storm happen
somewhere between 140 and 160 times on
average every year it's been happening
for hundreds and hundreds of years each
storm lasts for ten hours and can have
200 lightning strikes per hour on some
occasions it's been recorded as having a
lightning strike every second given the
right ingredients given the right
geography you can make a storm machine
and that's what Lake Maracaibo is so
here's what it's got going on the
Catatumbo region is surrounded by this
huge v-shape set of mountains and what
happens is you've got cold air coming in
off the Andes meeting with warm
Caribbean air and both of them settling
into the Catatumbo basin and that's the
ingredients you need for a storm
the locals are incredibly proud of the
rail and pagoda Catatumbo and they're
right to be proud of it not once but
twice the lightning storm has protected
the area from attack in the 1500s Sir
Francis Drake tried to attack the town
of Maracaibo and was repelled because
his ships were seen via the lightning
storm the same thing happened during the
fight for venezuelan independence when
the spanish were trying to attack and so
the right to show a certain amount of
affection for it the state of Zulia
in
wila is also besides being home to a
beautiful lightning storm a little dicey
the US State Department among other
countries governments say don't go there
it's got a bunch of drug traffickers and
various gangs of all kinds of stripes
it's a good place to get yourself
kidnapped and then ransomed it took my
co-founder Josh and I 15 hours to get to
this region of Venezuela and when we got
to Lake Catatumbo to get on the boats to
go to the island the boats weren't there
and by the time the boats were there it
was night this meant that we would need
lights to navigate the river which the
fishermen who were gonna take us were
like we're not doing that they were
afraid the lights would attract bandits
what they did suggest is that there was
a group of teenagers who would take us
with the lights and that they would
sleep on the island with us and that it
was all good because everyone was
bringing guns at that point we felt like
this doesn't feel like the best plan we
decided to ask a local fisherman there
who seemed like he'd been around the
block
do you think we should do this and he
just looked at us and he shook his head
no and so we watched the everlasting
lightning storm from the shore subscribe
here and watch more videos here we
should have gone we should have gone
with whatever we had guns we could have
fought the bandits it would have been
fine would have been fine